palabres
[Rires]
[Musique]
n'oubliez pas les paroles c'est très
simple si on va poser des questions sur
dorothée un chroniqueur qui sera allongé
ici il y a un deux trois quatre cinq on
ouvrira les trappes et il ya diverses
mais c'est aulas tient la loi attention
c'est pas
dans l'ue bonjour lui que moi je suis un
combien de parts de marché atteignait
chaque jour le club dorothée à 10% près
la tâche aujourd'hui 52 52% dorothée
c'était quoi
on ya eu du 55 y avait jamais dû 80%
allez c'est ce que j'ai sur ma fille
forcément donc mauvaise réponse de
jean-luc lemoine
c'est bon vous allez vous pouvez pas
venir mixer quoi vous faire aimer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
malabo
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mathieu citez-moi cinq dessins animés
qui passait dans le club dorothée alors
allongé sinon tête allongée sinon je
suis donc quoi s'y allonger ici jeanne
et serge que tout dépend de volley ball
wii dragon ball dorothée c'est bon ça ou
pas et le monde c'est bon
gd devant dermato rentrer chez dorothée
qui décide après dragon ball ouais
est-ce qu'à paris un petit goldorak
dorothée non de voter non il n'en faut
ça a créé une fois la dorothée il ya une
fois les dragon ball machin y avait quoi
dorothée à olive et tom
on vient de le dire iad et juliette je
t'aime
il y avait conduit candy la vaisselle
hormones et donc c'est perdu mathieu
delormeau je lui laisse une deuxième
chance je vous laisse une deuxième
chance mais si vous vous trompez où
jouera avec deux trappes
ah non non non non à celle ci ne s'est
pas une chance c'est sûr je vous met le
début d'un célèbre générique
ouais vous allez devoir santé continue
et les paroles pendant 15 secondes
attention c'est parti gillick génériques
[Musique]
et
bon moitié robot le plus vague père du
héros pyromanes
bioman ses défenseurs de la terre et
vous avez versé aux du mal intersidéral
alors voilà j'ai la banane ah non non
non c'est pas bon d'écouter coûtait pas
ça
venez 0 bioman et oman
ah ouais j'avais mopani gobain
céline robache agacé le ministère
n'avait pas dit que j'ai dit stop il est
courageux ou sochaux le vert jaune et
morne
[Applaudissements]
voilà avait pas ça dans pas nous pensons
à sa façon assez du pôle thomas
c'est bon ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]